thing I'm saying at the moment is
because you're trying to keep this pull
you're sort of like squinching your
fingers in a bit but that's all right so
once you've got the pole you can go
start with a finger then another finger
then another thing another finger it
won't change the pole so that's the good
thing you know if you sort of like go
well I'm going to move your fingers now
then the hand flattens so do it one
finger at a time all right so you're
here just you can look in front of you
see the pawn and you go
all right because they don't want to be
you don't want to be pointing up there
like I said there's some really good
shots of cytosensi where he's you know
he's in tonic and he's just there and
you'll see the fingers up
but it I don't know why it came to me
but I remember him just saying you know
this this is a little pole and it should
hold water
okay